well we have some exclusive details for
you tonight related to the Russia probe
in a letter obtained by this show an
attorney who represents a longtime Trump
advisor Roger stone has asked the White
House so to classify any materials that
would reveal whether stone was spied
upon by the FBI there is some evidence
that he was and if he indeed was he
would of course join Carter page and
Paul Manafort as individuals connected
to the Trump campaign who were spied on
without their knowledge so far the White
House has not commented on that letter
Michael Caputo is a former Trump
campaign advisor and he joins us tonight
Michael thanks a lot for coming on show
they do this is a pretty straightforward
request it's an interesting request is
there any reason that the White House
wouldn't help the rest of us know
whether stone was spied on well first I
want to make sure it's understood that I
I'm not in contact with Roger stone he's
my best friend but the court won't allow
me to speak to him I haven't spoken to
him or contacted him in any way since
the day he was arrested okay let me just
say since I think we have a First
Amendment still in this country I don't
know if we do the judge acknowledged
that why in the world I don't could a
judge tell you who you can talk to is an
adult taxpayer in this country right and
of course I've never they didn't ever
send me to the grand jury the mother
team I'm not on any witness list but for
some reason I think it's in vindictive
we're not allowed to speak to each other
Roger and I have known each other for 30
plus years sometimes we talked six or
seven times a day he talked me off the
ceiling I talked him off the ceiling and
stressful times but I haven't spoken to
him since the day I was in that he was
arrested I'm still kind of shocked about
that but I can tell you I really believe
that what the the attorney for Roger
stone requested should be granted and in
my opinion it's not just Roger stone
it's it's Carter page who's you know
surveillance documents need to be
revealed I mean Roger may not you know
by the time this investigation of the
Department of Justice is over which is
when we might see this material at the
earliest
Roger stones trial may already be over
in fact it probably will be so you know
you know unruhe vacuumed them and
releasing them at that point doesn't
help Roger stone at all doesn't reveal
all of the chicanery in
and and probably law-breaking that went
into surveilling Roger stone but it's
the same with Carter page and by the way
general Flynn in some way shape or form
as well there a lot there was a lot of
surveillance going on and we need to
know what it is and we need to know now
why wouldn't the White House help us
know that's what I don't understand and
general Flynn you're exactly right I
mean the Trump campaign was spied upon
by the Obama administration
we know this so why don't we have the
right to know the details of it well a
lot of this I don't understand because
if you remember about 3-4 months ago the
president said he was all set to to
declassify FISA documents and demanded
email or text messages between all the
different FBI agents who were who were
plant you know plotting this whole hoax
and we never saw that stuff a lot of
this stuff III don't understand but I'm
sure the president has a plan you know
I've just visited the president the Oval
Office recently and without you know we
didn't talk about Roger stone we were
both careful not to the president knows
he's my best friend and I know I met the
president through Roger stone in 1988 I
know he's close with Roger we were
careful not even to mention his name but
I think the president's paying very
close attention to this and that what
the let you know the letter from the
lawyer I think he might heat it I mean
let me tell you something he and the and
the first lady new chapter and verse of
what my family went through and I know
the president's paying attention to far
more people than just us yeah it'd be
nice to see some pardons a partner Roger
stone to begin michael gracey I'm real
worried about Don Jr with the Senate
committee I really agree the whole thing
is insane it rolls on it is zombie
investigation
great to see it thank you yeah thanks
doctor